What are your thoughts on electrolyte drinks specifically help M and T?
Is that okay to use or should I? We avoid it. The ingredients are sparkling, water, salt,
citric acid, magnesium, malate, potassium chloride, natural flavor, and stevia.
So electrolyte drinks, so what are our electrolytes? Our electrolytes are
minerals that your body needs. Why does our body need more minerals? Well, when you sweat out minerals,
if you're doing like sauna therapy on a daily basis, you could be sweating out and losing a lot
of minerals. If you're outside working in the summer heat, definitely supplementing with
minerals slash electrolytes would be a very wise thing. If you're an athlete and you're working out
heavily, you're sweating out a lot of your minerals. So there's nothing wrong with taking
electrolyte drinks. It could be a very wise thing to take if you're fitted in those kind of
categories. If you're not outside, you're not sweating out those things and you measured these
things in a blood test, which anybody who does a CBC and a complete metabolic panel, they're going
to measure their sodium, their chloride, their potassium and their calcium levels in their blood. Now,
normally, those are all those electrolytes are also function as buffering components of the blood.
So if your blood is off, then your electrolytes are way out of balance. So from a functional
standpoint, you have to use wisdom because they won't be out of balance on a blood test until
you've done a lot of insult. So just from going out sweating really hard, maybe several days in a
row, typically your blood values are going to still be within normal range. But if you're dehydrated,
you're not getting in, you know, your minerals through your food somehow, maybe you have some
gut issues, so you're not absorbing minerals real well. Maybe your diet is poor and you're then
out sweating and losing minerals. You can show differences in blood tests quite quickly.
However, your body is constantly trying to buffer the blood in order to keep a pH of 7.3,
4, 3, 5, or whatever it has to be. And it is using minerals from other parts of your body,
pull it into the blood. So taking electrolyte, using electrolyte drinks, taking minerals,
taking a good mineral supplement is a wise thing to do. Most electrolyte drinks have a decent
quality mineral. I do have a video, I think it's on our blog site, a video on, in a blog on
good minerals versus bad minerals. That's very important to look at. So I would suggest you go to
Cutters Clinic and search that out. I don't know what the title of the article is. I'll stop the
head. But there's there's supplements out there that really utilize really pretty minerals.
And you'll see in that article that I'm very much against the liquid ionic minerals that are kind
of a hot topic in the nutritional space right now. I think those are really a very poor quality
mineral. It's not how we're supposed to get our minerals. The ingredients that you listed off in
this, the salt, is just sodium chloride. That is replacing the sodium in the chloride in your gut.
In your bloodstream in your body, citric acid is just a carrier and something to help with the taste.
Magnesium valet is a good source of magnesium. Potassium chloride is a decent source of potassium.
So I don't have any problem with the ingredients in this. But there's some minerals out there that
use calcium carbonate. Really, that's just limestone. That's like edy dirt. That's just really poor
quality potassium carbonate. Really poor quality magnesium carbonates. It's like edy dirt. And that's
not how we're supposed to get our minerals. But it's super cheap. So a lot of companies don't care
about if it's good quality or not. They're just trying to sell supplements. Those are typically
supplements that you're going to buy in Wal-Mart or Charger or something like that. So you want to stay
away from that kind of stuff and use a good quality nutritional supplement. Taking bad quality minerals
not only is it good for you but it can be harmful for you because it can take up an absorption site
that if you're getting good minerals from your diet, then you don't absorb good those good minerals.
So it can be do you more harm than good even besides the fact that it can damage, can cause
other damage.